we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192davidp
this caller asks a very relevant
question take a listen
hey david um i was just wondering
whatever happened to that conga line
of bad hombres that were supposed to
come to america
and rape and kill us all or whatever
i haven't heard about them in a while i
was right
what happened to to all of that
because that seems to have disappeared
weird yep yeah so of of course the the
that's the immigrant caravan the migrant
caravan
um it was a big deal leading up to the
2018 midterms then we just didn't hear
about it again
they might bring it back up but as you
know donald trump doesn't like to cause
panic
so because trump doesn't like to cause
panic
i'm sure he wouldn't do something like
fear-mongering about a supposed
immigrant caravan right he would never
do because he doesn't want to cause
panic just like he didn't want to cause
panic
about coronavirus yeah now i'm going to
punch myself in the face
today's bonus show we will be talking
about what the hell happened during the
david pakman show vacation
don't miss it become a member instantly
at joinpackman.com